so Donald Trump and his continued
efforts to hang out with North Korean
dictator Kim jong-un but accomplished
nothing of substance has now gone to the
Demilitarized Zone on the North Korean
border with South Korea and actually
stepped into North Korea something a
sitting American president has never
done and immediately the trumpets are
arguing that this is a great thing
merely because it hasn't happened before
now later I'll get to the way in which
right-wing media covered Barack Obama's
dealings with North Korea and you'll
notice that there's a bit of a hypocrisy
a bit of a double standard there but
this is a weird thing that lots of
people seem to not understand just
because Donald Trump is the first to do
something doesn't mean that that's a
good thing Trump's the first president I
recall who visibly mocked a reporter's
handicap while running for president in
2016
that doesn't mean Trump's a great guy
for doing it because nobody did that
before and I think you can come up with
many other policy examples as well so
let's check out some video of what
Donald Trump said for some reason the
the the pool audio was off for just a
few seconds too long from the previous
live translation of Korean that was
going on so the first few seconds of
Donald Trump's statement are cut off but
we'll pick it up when the audio comes
back and we got to meet and stepping
across that line who's agreed on a lot
of progress and made a lot of
friendships have been made and this has
been in particular a great friendship so
I just want to thank you that was very
quick notice and I want to finish it
then there's a bit more from Donald
Trump right after the translation of
that first piece took place a lot of
really positive things are happening I'm
glad you could be here to say it but
tremendous positivity really great
things are happening and in a lot of
places but we met and we liked each
other from day one and that was very
important the way that Donald Trump
looks at Kim jong-un as the translation
is happening to gauge whether Kim
jong-un likes what Trump said is so
reminiscent of like the fifth grader who
wants the middle school kids to like him
and is constantly monitoring the
reactions on their faces as they talk
Trump also reportedly has invited Kim
jong-un to come to the White House which
would be very very interesting to say
the least so I think the analysis here
is maybe simpler than some might think
it is a good thing to try to have good
relationships with other countries for
the betterment of humanity okay avoiding
conflict and violence that's good
now some are being critical of Donald
Trump's actions because they say Oh
Trump is legitimizing Kim jong-un even
though Kim jong-un is a violent dictator
I don't think this is the right critique
number one the US has a long history of
legitimizing violent dictators that's
not new number two yes Kim jong-un has
been and will continue to use these
meetings with Trump and these invites
from Trump to propagandize internally
within North Korea and propagandized the
North Korean people but who cares he's
doing that anyway and that's not really
at issue here outside of North Korea
Trump doing this does not legitimize Kim
jong-un in any materially relevant way
so I don't think that's the right
critique the problem is that Trump
doesn't realize he's getting played okay
before the first meeting with Kim
jong-un Trump bragged about how he was
able to secure a meeting with with a
North Korean leader any president could
have met with any North Korean dictator
it has been the American presidents who
didn't want to do it without some
preconditions because it would likely be
pointless
and case in point none of the North
Korean dictator's including Kim jong-un
so far in his dealings with Trump have
stuck to these tired vague promises that
they've been making for decades and
Trump doesn't realize that he's getting
played that's the real critique and
because Donald Trump accomplishes
nothing in these meetings remember
missile testing has continued the
propaganda has continued the threats
have continued this suggests that the
United States is okay with treating
regimes that oppress and pillage their
own populations in the same way that we
treat Western liberal democracies it's
an incredible hypocrisy but it's also
not surprising because we know that
Donald Trump has been very taken with
the likes of Putin and duterte and I
forget the rest of the list and Kim
jong-un is on that list and he's been
increasingly alienating France and
Germany and the United Kingdom and
Canada so that's the real critique
legitimizing Kim jong-un it's kind of a
weak critique and we legitimize Kim
jong-un in many different ways all the
time
we shouldn't understate the value of
this also as a stunt to take attention
away from trumps absolutely disastrous
failed diplomacy with Iran and the
almost war that Donald Trump started
because when Fox News and whoever else
on the Trump astride starts praising
Donald Trump for doing this for stepping
into North Korea and continuing to
praise gushingly Kim jong-un it does
frame Trump as a successful diplomat
which he is not remember and again he's
accomplished nothing practical or
tangible with North Korea and it takes
attention away from the almost true
disaster that was Trump's authorized
strike against Iran and then at the last
second calling it back supposedly after
being told by the military what the
civilian casualties would be even though
it is extraordinarily difficult to
believe that the military would not have
briefed Trump on that earlier on in the
game one of today's sponsors is impeach
the card slap game you cannot slap
Donald Trump in real life but you can
slap him in
hilarious fast-paced two-player card
game and you can get it for 10% off when
you go to david pakman.com slash impeach
and use the coupon code pakman show at
checkout all one word awesome for
parties when you're having a few drinks
I've been playing it with some friends
of mine currently has a 5 out of 5 star
rating on Amazon and it combines clever
satire about the Trump administration
with really funny high-quality cartoon
artwork all in a really lively card game
that's easy to learn but it stays
interesting every time you play it
because of how well designed it is and
really how much thought went into the
humor and the political commentary the
game covers a ton of themes global
warming Russian collusion tax cuts for
the wealthy impeach the card slap game
is perfect if you're looking for
something fun and casual to do with your
politically minded friends or family
members you might even learn something
new about the Trump administration while
you're playing the game it's a perfect
gift for anyone who has a sense of humor
about Trump or get it for yourself and
have a really fun and witty game to play
when people come over you can even play
a tournament style get impeach the cards
slap game by going to david pakman.com
slash impeach and get 10% off when you
use the coupon code pakman show at
checkout all one word